all right what's going on guys this is
rob and a lot of you guys have asked me
to make a video about
or at least about the characters from
invincible uh so we're gonna start here
with alan the alien because he's one of
my favorite characters he's an amazing
character right so
the origin of alan the alien in
invincible or invincible
origin of alan alien or alan alien
origin i'm not really sure what i'm
gonna title it yet i'm gonna have to
figure it out right you gotta hit that
seo man
search engine optimization i've already
got comics dominated now i gotta find a
way to dominate invincible so
here's the crazy thing about this so for
any of you guys who follow me on patreon
and we do the invincible videos more in
depth over there you guys know that we
we talked about how alan the alien was
going to have a super important role
later on
one of the things that i want to specify
here is it's going to have mild spoilers
but
i'm going to avoid them as best i can
but the important thing
is that with alan the alien he's really
the result of
experimentation and genetic engineering
right and so the way this worked out
is that the anopens were basically a
race that was invaded by the viltromites
at one point and the result of this is
that uh in a matter of days
the whole planet was conquered now
ultimately the unopened basically
like abandoned their planet right they
just kind of took off and one of the
reasons for this is they did not want to
become one of the races that had been
conscripted by the viltromites and
that's one of the things that
viltromites do
because of the fact that there's so few
of them it doesn't really make any sense
despite their longevity and their
capabilities
to throw all their eggs in one basket
and to just constantly take the entirety
of their forces
and jump from world to world and even
with their newly formed plan which is to
send a singular vulture might to an
individual world like
uh omniman showing up to earth that even
then if omniman's destroyed then there's
like
one less viltrumite right and so the
result of this is that they would
basically conquer worlds and then they
would force the various denizens of
those worlds and to effectively being an
army right more or less like a garrison
for that part of uh of existence right
that part of the galaxy or the universe
or what have you
but for the for the anopens themselves
the desire was to essentially
create a force that was capable of
fighting off the viltrumites either
killing them or at the very least uh
preying on the idea that the vulture
might realize there's so few of their
races and basically just giving up right
just being like it's not worth losing
this many of our number to conquer this
world we'll just talk it up to a lost
cause or we'll come back with a bigger
army later
on or something along those lines and so
in order to achieve that the anopens
basically started delving into genetic
manipulation and it was immediately
approved right as soon as the idea was
put forward it was like let's start
genetically engineering our children so
they can essentially be as powerful as
the as the various viltrumites
the problem with this is that every
single instance of there being some kind
of an unborn fetus being experimented on
when the fetus was born
it was born with either physical
deformations or with mental handicaps
the only exception to that is alan and
so as soon as he was born he was
immediately experimented on but they
were just trying to figure out exactly
what it is about him that makes him work
how in the world he's this strong that
kind of a thing to see whether or not
their experiment
actually paid off the way that it wanted
to and given every single
instance of examination it did it worked
like it was supposed to and so
ultimately they actually had sent him
out and had him face off against all
these various threats that existed out
there and time and time again he proved
to be successful there was no threat out
there that he could not overcome
until he came across the viltrumites and
ultimately they
thrashed him right they absolutely
trashed him and so the results of this
is that recovering from his injuries
the entire experiment was considered to
be a failure right they said okay we've
managed to create a super powerful being
out there
but he can't really achieve the goal
that we created him for right he they
were you know alan the alien exists to
defeat the viltrumites he couldn't do it
the experiment's a failure and so what
they ended up doing instead is they
basically tasked him
with a kind of fake role which is
champion evaluation officer and
essentially he would travel around
the entirety of the cosmos and find
individuals out there that were capable
of overpowering him but were inherently
good and would stand against the vulture
mites and so if he was able to find one
of those people then the argument was he
would basically join the coalition of
worlds which stands against the
viltrumites and that they would
basically be recruited to their cause
this ultimately led him to kind of being
duped into believing that he was going
to
a planet that was basically called ura
uh in reality it was earth right he was
just
told it was a different name he
basically got there and then his story
unfolds exactly the way you're familiar
with in the show there's
one big caveat to his character yet that
has not been
explored and it's the single most
important thing when it comes to alan
the alien the
reality is that his experiment was not a
failure instead with alan the alien
because of the nature of the
experimentation and his physiology and
so on he's
basically like a saiyan in the
invincible universe those of you guys
who follow dragon ball z what that means
is that every time he fights an opponent
when he recovers he gets
stronger and so it's one of these things
when he fought nolan on multiple
occasions
and got absolutely crushed or any other
vulture mites that were out there he
recovered and became
stronger after that particular conflict
and so he wasn't
inherently born stronger than
viltrumites but he's certainly getting
there and there actually will come a
point where he is there and then
actually exceeds it right like alan
alien becomes
super powerful and invincible it's
really cool that's why i say
he's one of these these characters that
just slides under the radar and if
you're not paying attention like he he
was just
he he comes out of nowhere it's just
like this ridiculously op guy
one of the crazy things though and this
is something that i'm not going to spoil
here but i will say the guy who
basically approved the entire operation
the leader of the coalition of worlds is
a guy named thaddeus that has an
amazing story right his backstory is
ridiculously cool
and really has a heavy hand in the
involvement of a freddie mercury
right the leader of the vulture mine
empire
technically his name's thrag but you
guys have all started calling him
freddie mercury so that's what we're
gonna go ahead and call him from right
now for right like literally in all the
videos we're just gonna call him freddie
mercury but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end if you
are new here to comments explain make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob corps if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
foreign